you bet your ass I'm wearing a sailor
moon' shirt the Matrix Reloaded is a
sequel to one of the best movies ever
made I love the first matrix is one of
my favorite movies I have reviewed it
before but I want to talk about Matrix
Reloaded and Matrix Revolutions why well
because John wick is coming out soon and
Keanu Reeves is in that film as well as
Laurence Fishburne so this is the
perfect time for me to fill in the gaps
in my matrix trilogy reviews and talk
about the two films I have not yet
reviewed the first Matrix was hugely
impactful on me and my friends we made a
ton of matrix short films in my review
the first matrix which by the way
there's going to be a link for at the
end of this video I showed you an
embarrassing clip from one of our
earliest short films that was definitely
tributing The Matrix I'm going to do
that again and reload it in revolutions
because why not and that's gonna be the
end of this video let's talk about
Matrix Reloaded this was one of my most
anticipated movies ever I couldn't wait
for this movie the trailers looked
amazing all of the cast was coming back
there were cows keys we're going to
return to direct and right everything
was just poised for incredible success
because The Matrix was so damn good that
it was hard to believe that the same
people could possibly make anything that
was bad it just couldn't happen
The Matrix Reloaded was going to be
perfect it was going to be the greatest
movie ever it was going to be a
transcendent movie experience it was
going to take us to the heavens and back
again the ultimate question of life was
going to be answered by the Matrix
Reloaded everything was just going to
come into focus and this film was going
to take us to Valhalla and back and
everything was going to be amazing
and it kind of was disappointing a lot
of people compared The Matrix Reloaded
and the Matrix Revolutions to the Star
Wars prequels by saying that they simply
were just vastly disappointing movies
too focused on effects and less focused
on a good story
I personally don't view them that
harshly they are disappointing yes
absolutely they're nowhere near as good
as that first film but when you go into
a film expecting everything to be
perfection well then it's really tough
for anything to meet your expectations
and you will likely leave disappointed
no matter what there are a lot of things
I like about Matrix Reloaded I think it
did a lot of things really right I think
it actually did a handful of things
better than the first matrix LP it's a
very small handful but there are some
things in this film that are better for
one Zion it's a real breathing place in
this film occupied with hundreds of
people and you actually get to see it
you see its operation you understand how
it works and this entire place that was
only referenced in the first matrix as
this place we were supposed to really
care about is now really fleshed out and
reloaded and you get a sense of
desperation of urgency in these people
because the machines are growing to
their city and they're going to be there
very soon so a war between the last
remaining humans and the machines is on
horizon and Morpheus and Trinity are
some of the only people remaining who
genuinely believe in the one neo played
by Keanu Reeves so the fact that we
could just see a living breathing
workable Zion in this film definitely is
better than the first because in the
first it was just like hey Zion is
important okay well why is it important
because it is
okay so maybe not a handful of things
better probably just the Zion thing yeah
just about everything else and reloaded
is not as good as the first so let's
just stop comparing it to the first for
now and just talk about the film what I
like about this movie the action
sequences that are in camera my favorite
action scene in this movie is easily the
Chateau sword fight this is entirely in
camera for the most part and it is
really well choreographed very intense
and Keanu Reeves just kicks so much ass
in this scene and really this whole
movie he does so much as usual of the
fight choreography and stunts on his own
say what you will about him as an actor
but as a physical actor he's one of the
best working today he throws himself
into these scenes and he makes it
believable all of the in-camera stuff
during the highway chase is super fun a
lot of really white knuckled sequences
there and impossibly the most famous
scene in the movie which has become
known as the burly brawl where neophytes
a ton of clones of Smith the stuff
that's in camera where it's actually
Keanu Reeves and all these clones that's
awesome you kind of watch it and your
mouth starts to drop a little bit and
you just realize how much work and
effort was put into these sequences and
you really have to sit back and give
them a round of applause for all the
things they're able to do in this movie
because if you've ever picked up a
camera and try to make a movie it's hard
it is hard work and when you see this
film and all the effort and care that
was put into those technical aspects of
it you really do have to give them some
praise for that notice that I keep
saying the in-camera stuff is great
because it is the CG stuff Wow they went
too far there's a time period in
Hollywood during the 2000s decade where
they were just like let's just make
fully CGI people and everyone's gonna
buy it
movies like Blade 2 used to fully render
digital Wesley Snipes and it looked bad
Terminator 3 at the time had Arnold
hanging from the back of this crane and
it just looks so unrealistic and you
don't buy it for a minute by far though
the worst offense of this is the Matrix
Reloaded I have grown to call the Smiths
in this movie balloon people because
that's what they look like and in the
most mind-blowing ly awful sequence in
this movie neo jumps on top of all of
the Smith's heads and this is a fully
digital sequence and it just looks bad
where the first movie had a smaller
budget and everything really had to be
done with expert care and there couldn't
be too much CGI in regards to creating
people they always had to show real
people doing this or at least insert a
real person into a scenario this movie
just has fully rendered digital people
just flying everywhere
and it is no longer convincing and to be
honest when I first saw this in 2003 it
really didn't convince me then either it
was always very noticeable also what's
really lacking from these action
sequences is a sense of pain everyone
feels like a superhero in the first film
you kind of felt like neo was getting
his ass handed to him and that he could
actually die it was dirty dust flew off
of people when they fought and in this
movie it's so glossy and clean and you
barely see any blood you don't really
get the sense that anyone's actually
hurting each other that's my little rant
on the special effects of this movie
there's a lot of really great sequences
as I said but whenever it starts to rely
too much on CGI it just doesn't hold up
anymore and as I said it didn't really
hold up that well for me even in oh
three reloaded is that rare film that
can actually be viewed in two different
ways it can be viewed as a
straightforward popcorn film with a lot
of great kung-fu and action sequences
and a lot of teenagers myself included
back in o3 or perfectly fine with that
but it can also be viewed in a far
deeper way there's a lot of analysis to
be given to this movie once you learn of
things in the past when neo encounters
the architect and the architect starts
to spill all the details about the
former incarnations of the matrix and
Neos choices and the various paths that
he can choose to take and all of these
things can be attributed to a lot of
religious things today
there's Buddhist references in this film
those references to the Bible and
Christianity that gets really
heavy-handed in revolutions which we'll
talk about when we view that film but
for me personally if you get too into
that with reloaded and revolutions you
can kind of fall into that trap that
I've seen a lot of people fall into with
the prequels of Star Wars
start over analyzing something you start
getting really deep into it until you
become obsessed with it and all of a
sudden you're seeing all these things
and you convince yourself that it's this
amazing masterpiece when it's really not
now I'm not saying there's nothing to
discover in this film that there's
nothing under the surface because there
is the Wachowski x' have always been
filmmakers that definitely try even in
their bad films like really bad films
like Jupiter ascending you can tell
they're giving effort they're not just
going to approach something in half acid
they might make a shitty movie but they
definitely try so there are things in
reloaded to discover it's just that I
think a lot of people have taken it way
too far and built an entire world around
it then maybe that what ciao skis
weren't even going for so let's get back
to talking about the filmmaking one
thing about this movie that I think is
awesome and just really great is the
score I've listened to the score I don't
even know how many times tons of times
the stuff that Don Davis did with Juno
reactor in this film created some really
awesome beats I love the score for this
movie the soundtrack is bangin
interestingly the original score was
actually far different Don Davis
composed music that was much more
cinematic but the Wachowskis wanted more
of a techno edge so they hired Juno
reactor to write over that music as well
as Rob Dugan to compose a completely new
song for the Chateau sword fight
you
for me the Matrix Reloaded is a film
that I can watch every once in a while
every time I watch it I'm just a little
disappointed because I always remember
how excited I was and how it just didn't
live up to that but you can watch it for
it's amazing action sequences the end
camera stuff the CG stuff you're just
watching you're like oh my god that what
are they doing like there's even a part
where they have domino toppling sound
effects and bowling pins sound effects
it's like they knew it was shit and they
were just making it Looney Tunes but
taken as a straight popcorn film you can
enjoy the Matrix Reloaded on that level
I respect them for trying with some of
the deeper stuff but unfortunately
there's a lot of unanswered questions
that still even revolutions weren't
really explored enough like Agent Smith
Hugo Weaving just kind of returning and
he's like you set me free mr. Henderson
surprised to see me oh so he set you
free okay well that explains everything
in the end to me The Matrix Reloaded is
not terrible it's a watchable film but
the idea of a sequel to the matrix being
just watchable is so sad I'm gonna give
the Matrix Reloaded a b-minus
it's okay all these years later it's
fine it just it didn't reach the heights
that it was going for and it relied on
CG way too much so guys look forward to
my review of the Matrix Revolutions
coming very soon before John wick
chapter 2 which I can't wait to see oh
my gosh hope that's great guys thank you
once again for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes the year 2003 the
characters neo
and a squid that looks suspiciously
phallic here's a clip from one of our
earliest and most embarrassing short
films neo vs. squid
you